you are the director of FBI and one of
your top three issues was I really want
to find out what the hell happened with
Epstein do you have enough access to
find out exactly what happened and come
out with the intel on that maybe not
exactly what happened but pretty much
pretty damn close and how long would it
take you to be able to give that report
to the American people case like that
I don't know I mean it depends on how
many people get brought in and I mean
and then also you're getting with
finances you have to do subpoena bank
records and there's a lapse in time
there I think you could probably do a
pretty good job in a year
pretty good job in a year yeah okay so
within within a year you could get that
Intel to us especially if you had you
know I don't know five five really
staunch case agents and and Intel
analysts or two and that's all you
worked on this is the this is why he
could never be a manager because he
wants to investigate perhaps the biggest
most important case in the country and
says I can do it five people if I had a
manager would want 500 that's true